Hollywood the actors they're they're
split where their talent are
ideologically at odds with their
institutions and I'm not going to sit
here and tell you who's right or who's
wrong we we can have a Palestine Israel
discussion later I'm just pointing out
they're starting to fire people the
industry is not doing so well in the
meantime seems like Independent Media is
is is is just skyrocketing I mean a few
years ago if I would have talked about
the sound of Freedom people would not
have believed me if I would have said
there's going to be a new studio they're
going to launch a movie it's going to
defy all expectations crack into the top
of the box office 100 what is that $200
million 250 $250 million people would be
like what dude you can't beat Hollywood
and now Hollywood's dying I mean billion
dollar loss for Disney how you guys
doing is sound of Freedom still in
theaters it is in around the world it is
throughout the world but in the US we
just had the last day in the theaters it
was last Friday or Thursday yeah